Anybody calls my office and says, hey, I just have a question for the doctor.
Can I just ask him this question?
My secretary will say, no.
Okay?
She's very good at screening the, it's saving me, okay?
And she will let somebody talk to me.
Even if you're a doctor and say, I just want to have a doctor, I just want to talk to him.
He'll, he'll maybe answer.
He'll maybe call you back, but you can't talk to him.
So that's just the way I have to protect myself.
So if your doctor sometimes I'll call you back.
If I know you, if I don't know you, I may not call you back.
If you try to sell me something, you're definitely not going to get a call back.
So if, if you're a patient, the way to start is with what we call a case review.
It's also a consultation.
And this is very detailly laid out on my website.
It says, first steps.
Contact the office, schedule a case review.
Then you go download the paperwork.
It's all on the website.
Fill out the paperwork.
Set it back in.
We'd have the case review.
And I have some papers that don't do anything beyond that.
Because they didn't like me or something.
Or they had a different thought.
They wanted to go in a different direction or just wanted some questions answered.
I'm never going to give you diagnostic information of the case review.
So don't call and get a case review thinking that I'm going to tell you how to treat you in life
because that's not going to happen.
So that at that case review, it's for me, there's people that I don't accept as patients, too.
So if I don't feel like you're a person that really wants to get better,
I don't accept you as a patient.
I don't like to lose.
So, and believe it or not, there's a number of patients that typically tend to be chronic.
I'm patients that they're getting a lot of secondary gain.
You know, they don't have to work anymore.
They don't have to do this anymore. They don't have to do it anymore.
You have to be careful and guard yourself from that if you're in a chronic illness.
It's just human nature.
Hey, I get a lot out of being sick.
I don't have to do anything anymore.
You have to guard yourself.
You have to really check your heart on that.
You wouldn't be at a rife conference today if that was you, so I can say that.
Of course.
Speaking of videotaping.
So, the next way is if you choose to do a genetic consultation with me,
there's a cost to that.
So the cost to the case review is $199.
The cost for the genetic consultation you have had to do on your 23 or me,
23 and me, or you have to be in the process of doing that.
And then once you get the data back, then you call and schedule.
Or if you already have the data, you can schedule with 23 and me review.
That's what we call it.
Then I need your user name and password.
You know, I'll get your user name and password.
I'll produce a document that I said is about 30 pages.
It'll have a whole bunch of these on there.
All the data of all these G's.
It'll have a whole bunch of written information where it took all that written stuff.
It's out on this slide.
Those little boxes that had written stuff, it'll have all that.
So solely looking at that can be extremely helpful.
And you are required to watch the videos on the genetic slides.
Because I'm not taking my time to re-educate you.
So that's what we have in these conferences for to educate you.
That's what we're going to put this in a video for.
And put it on our website to educate you.
And it made a whole bunch of videos like this,
writing through versions 23 and me.
Educating there.
So I don't want to have to say it again.
So I want you to watch those videos.
And really honestly, at the end of the day, I was worth wrote.
So I need you to do your homework at your side.
And then I'm going to make recommendations.
So that 23 and me reviews only about 15 to 30 minutes.
And then I will send you my recommendations based upon that.
Which will be another sheet of paper with some specific nutritional recommendations.
And you can choose to buy those supplements for me.
Or we have a lot of patients that are from other doctors.
And they can get them from their doctor.
So get them from somebody who uses those supplements.
Or if you're a doctor, you can set it up and get those specific supplements.
That cost for that is 425.
So it includes the gene report.
It includes the supplement report, which is the recommendations.
And it may include that histamine sheet.
Or you have a bunch of comp defects of how I wrote a paper on that.
But actually, I put that up on the website now, too.
So I put the histamine sheet up on the website, too.
And then if you follow up on me on that, let's say,
OK, three weeks down the road, well, I feel a little bit better.
But I'm not feeling 100% better or I feel worse.
If I do, you can't just call in the office and say,
can you just ask the doctor when I should do?
Should I say all this?
You have to talk.
You're paid for my time.
You're paid for my staff's time.
It's literally what you're doing.
So the only way we can figure it to be fair across the board is if you talked,
you can set up another telephone visit with me.
And it's 15-minute chunks.
And the cost for me is $187.
The cost for my staff is $65.
My staff, Janelle, is extremely educated.
She's been with me a number of years.
She can probably answer most of your questions.
So you'd set up an appointment with her.
Or you'd set up an appointment with me.
And you'd get those questions answered.
And we put that all together in a written form.
It's called our 23-and-B agreements.
Because we want everybody to understand the boundaries just so it's safe.
So like, oh, listen to me.
Or one person got way too much time or whatever.
So everybody's fair.
And it's just fair across the board.
So before you do that, you have her set that document.
And it is one of the last slides in here.
If we get to it, which I don't doubt, we will.
But it's a 23-and-B agreement that you'll get emailed to.
So I always like to be completely above board, upfront.
What's going on?
The last way that people come to me is to do a full program with me.
And that's here with me.
You're in our office for two full days.
And that's a right program.
So I don't take people anymore.
I just don't have time to hand just to have an autoimmune disease.
Because you just test me on what I should take for mercury toxicity.
I just can't do that anymore.
I just can't.
So it's either just watching my website, learning from it.
Download a mailbox.
Number two is a case review.
And then deciding what to do from there.
And number three is you do the genetic review piece with recommendations.
And then you can do follow-up consults with me.
But again, those are only based upon your genes.
And the follow-up consults you get.
I'm still having problems.
And what should I do for mercury toxicity?
Well, I don't know.
I didn't do an exam on you.
So we're a little limited with that.
So though they're really med for people who are using a really good functional doctor outside of our clinic.
But you just need the genetic piece.
Or they're really doing a really good job managing their health.
And they just need, this is the missing piece of the puzzle.
Can I get help with this?
I can't find anybody locally.
There's probably only about 250 doctors that know what I'm talking about here in the world, honestly.
So it's becoming, it's just a lot of study.
You know, I just did a seminar.
A couple of months ago for doctors.
And they want to learn live.
And I'm like, okay, are you doing this genetic technique?
And you're talking about it like that.
So it's fun.
Why are you learning this stuff?
Of course, I don't like golf.
So I guess it's give a take.
Does anyone do this with you or are you solo?
I am by myself.
I don't work good together with people.
I have a very high expectation.
Sorry about that.
Do I need B12?
We kind of already covered this, but actually our genetic profile comes out with a reading.
So there's other reasons.
If I have an MTR in MTRRG, we didn't really get on this really hard.
But this is how we recycle B12.
This person with a double allele MTRRG defect does not recycle B12 very much.
B12 very well.
Better fact, if you do a blood test on their B12, they might have extremely high B12.
Why in the world?
Which parts of that B12?
Their blood test is like off the chart.
Well, it's not getting into the cells.
So your genetics are really important.
Also, how do you get B12?
So if you're taking B12, how you absorb B12 is through this chemical called intrinsic factor
that then has to bring it across a healthy gut.
You don't have, if I am F-U-T2G defects in other genes, that are not even absorbing B12 very well.
That's why you have to use sublegal B12.
And the form of B12 is really important based upon your other defects.
Right?
It's not that difficult.
These are other genes that support the making of sand.
We can't get into all of these.
But this is all in this pathway.
This is a methionine pathway.
That's all purpose is to make sand.
It's so important for you to make sand that God made multiple pathways for you to make sand.
So if you have defects in certain pathways, it will be carried on other pathways.
And I should say, these are really cool charts.
I love them.
Thank you Dr. Ben Lynch for putting these together.
His graphic team put this together.
If you're a practitioner wanting to learn this stuff, I'd suggest you go through Dr. Ben Lynch's courses.
What's interesting about this is you've got a bunch of questions about mercury toxicity.
So let's just talk about toxicity in general.
Toxicity can block any of these pathways.
So I can have a perfectly open pathway, meaning I have no genetic defects.
But I have a toxicity that blocks that pathway.
This is one of the theories actually.
With why there's such a high incidence of autism in the United States,
versus other countries, that it's been research that used the same vaccine schedule.
Here was one of the conclusive differences.
In the United States, doctors are taught that you should go home and give your child Tylodol
so that they don't have any ill effects of the vaccine.
Tylodol blocks the MTHFR pathway.
So if I have a doubly little defective MTHFR C677,
I already have a 65% of the average reduction of that function of that gene.
And then you get Tylodol.
My kid is toast.
Other countries that don't have the same autism rate don't suggest Tylodol.
So this is where I've got do vaccines cause autism?
No, the toxicity causes autism.
You have those defects and you have other compromised things.
You're going to have blood, you're going to have brain issues because of that.
So if you have to choose a paid medication,
and if you don't have that one ABP1G that detoxes insads,
and that's clear, Tylodol is not your best choice anyhow.
Matter of fact, there was another friend that I met Dr. Susie Cohen in California
who was a functional pharmacologist who were a really nice book of the genes.
Oh, she didn't write a book.
But she wrote a book of the pharmacology and its function in the body and the ill effects of it.
And she has a really nice chart system of how different pharmacosinicals block different pathways.
So this is another reason why I may say I'm not going to take a patient.
So first it's on multiple medications.
It's like this is going to be a really difficult case.
So you're blocking so many pathways with those medications.
Your own benzodiazepines?
It's going to be a very difficult case.
So the least amount of medications you can be on, the better off you're going to be.
Yep, I think she's done a wonderful job.
When her book, Dr. Susie Cohen's book, be helpful for a practitioner, especially I think it's really important.
So these are all different genes in this pathway. I'm not going to go through them.
This is an interesting window. I touched on this before the BAT gene.
This one here, because this is so important in having a person having excess methanine with cancer patients.
So if you're a cancer patient with a lot of BAT gene defects, you have to be careful that methanine isn't driving your cancer.
And a lot of those people, though, we test our patients with kinesiology as well.
But just looking at it for the genetic standpoint, if you have a lot of BAT genes and you defects and you have cancer,
probably good to be able to much lower methanine diet.
Methanine isn't beta acid. Beta acids are found in proteins.
It's what a low protein diet.
I have a video solely on that. If you have cancer, it's called cancer diets. I have a whole web page on that.
Transulferation pathway. You're also called the CBS pathway.
It's how you get rid of reactive oxygen species.
So that is how you make glutathione.
How you make SOD. We touched on those two things already.
How you get rid of sulfates, sulfites.
So people with defects in this pathway, this, the CBS gene can be like a break.
You have a defect in that. You'll push this pathway really hard.
And these are the people that have issues with sulfites.
Anybody have issues with sulfites? Can't drink one.
Causes them to be all red-faced. Causes them to feel sick.
Yep. It can be the sulfites in there. It can be the histamine in there.
So you'll look at this pathway. You need to support this pathway.
They have a deficiency in glutathione. They're not getting rid.
They're producing excess sulfites, excess ammonia.
So people with defects here are going to produce a lot of ammonia, especially if you have urea cycle defects.
That's going to cause a lot of symptoms too. Similar to proxy nitrate.
That's not going to have the ill effects of causing heart disease.
And this is really causing cancer, but you can have a lot of eukides.
Fatigue is excess ammonia production.
That's the CBS gene. It comes from homocysteed.
And you all remember the homocyste is in the bottom of the limousine cycle.
That's a recycled macrosanum, right?
You all got that 100% of the testitis game.
And then the CBS gene takes it down to the glutathione and such.
So there's your ammonia symptoms.
It kind of sells like chronic Lyme, doesn't it?
So this is where you go. So why does...
I have chronic Lyme because I have all these symptoms, right?
Okay, there's this bacteria, and it's colon infections.
It's flowing around in your body.
How does it actually cause these symptoms, right?
What causes symptoms because it affects pathways?
And then excess things are made like proxy nitrate in ammonia.
And that's what's causing symptoms.
Do you understand?
So that's as you dig into why, why, why, why?
You keep asking that question, why?
That's where you're going to get to some base things that you can really help a patient with.
I can't help you with your vision.
What are the symptoms?
It is growth retardation.
Okay, so this would be an excess ammonia in a baby and such.
But mainly muscular fatigue, poor coronation.
Just all sorts of muscle symptoms and neurological symptoms and things like that.
Because it's better where it is.
If it's in the muscles, you're going to have a muscle-based system.
Symptoms, if it's in the brain, you're going to have more upper-border neuro symptoms.
Okay?
Is this helpful?
Everybody's so quiet, is it?
Yes.
No, I just made this two days ago.
Will it be on the website?
As soon as we get that video back.
Or you can buy it from Mike.
I said I did.
You should buy it from Mike.
Sorry, Mike.
It's never going to help you back again.
The biopsyram pathway.
So this river, the MTHFR through the folate pathway, feeds the metanine cycle to make saline,
which then feeds the transolpheration pathway to get rid of sulfate sulfites
to make sure you're not making excess ammonia, to get rid of ammonia,
to get rid of reactive oxygen species, reactive nitrogen species.
That's your glutathione, that's your SOD, all those things.
That also feeds the biopsyram pathway.
The biopsyram pathway is where you make your neurotransmitters.
Kind of important when you're talking about mood issues.
Though I know nobody has mood issues here, but we still have to go over this.
So what does your mood come from?
Well, it does come from things that you think about all day.
Yeah, it does, right?
But so there is, when we talk about your brain, there's a chemical component.
And that's what we're going to talk about with the genetics.
And there's a neurological component.
And that's what we talk about when I do a lecture on functional neurology.
So when you're dealing with a live patient or a person with brain cancer,
you have to re-mill these pathways.
So when they have inflammation in the brain, or when you're talking about Alzheimer's or dementia.
So you're dealing with inflammation in the brain.
So when I have inflammation in the brain, it's going to physically affect the neurological pathways.
It's also going to chemically affect these metabolic pathways that we're going to talk about.
So the neurological pathways are the physical neurons.
So my prefrontal cortex has to connect with other parts of the brain.
The prefrontal cortex is my part of the brain that makes me human.
So this is where logic comes in. This is where I'm thinking.
This is where I'm calculating. This is where speech comes in.
My dog has a prefrontal cortex, but it's really little.
So I can tell her to set.
And she can learn the set because she does have a prefrontal cortex.
But if another dog is running over there, her prefrontal cortex is not large enough
to override what the midbrain is telling her, the archaeocortex, the deep part of the brain.
That's your instinctual part of the brain.
That functions outside of reason many times.
She wants to obey. She loves me dearly, but her archaeocortex is sensing she needs to protect.
So she's going to jump up and bark.
And I have to go physically grab her and drag her back because her prefrontal cortex is too small.
Her archaeocortex, her instinctual brain, is taking over.
Yes.
It's true for some humans too.
So as a human, we have a larger physical prefrontal cortex.
But when we have inflammation in the brain from a straight neurological pathway issue,
it can block that communication from a prefrontal cortex to the midbrain.
And I start doing things that are beyond reason.
So is it true for patients it was funny, but is absolutely true for patients.
So patients that have behavioral issues have typically a neurological problem,
physically neurological problem.
And it can be caused from inflammation, it can cause by disuse, it can cause for everything.
And they have a chemical problem which we're going to talk about in a second.
So neurological problem can happen because of inflammation because of a chronic life or something like that.
But it can happen because of disuse, it can happen because the pathway was never created.
That's what disciplining your child is.
It's created a neurological pathway.
So if you don't discipline your child and tell them no, you can't do that.
How are they ever supposed to know that they can't do that?
That's education.
If my dog can learn not to go on the neck, my grand kid can learn not to go on the neck.
Following, that's brain-based therapy.
When you fire a pathway, that's brain-based therapy.
When I learned calculus in high school, that was brain-based therapy.
I fired a pathway that didn't exist.
I didn't know what the teacher was talking about.
Just what you're doing today.
You know anything like this.
And if I'm doing a good job teaching you, oh, I get it.
And you'll be related to things that you know about.
Now that pathway is starting to form.
And I understand that pathway in your brain for genetics is just a gravel road right now.
And maybe it's a too late highway because I've been doing this a long time.
But if you get into this and learn and learn and learn no matter what it is you're going to do.
I'm not asking you to get into this.
It becomes a too late highway, in a four late highway.
It's a job that you've done for years.
You're an expert at a county, you're an expert at whatever you're an expert at.
Because you fire that pathway over and over and over and over.
The more you use it, the more it builds.
As long as you have the nutrients to build that pathway and you have everything else in place.
But you get rid of the biochemistry.
You have issues with that pathway.
So this person, they could remember things in their whole life.
They were a attorney.
They remember all these case things.
And now they have this rapid insect dementia.
Why?
When the pathway was there, but they have some source of inflammation, maybe blow it out the pathway, or ed or some sort of chemical imbalance, loss of chemistry.
So the normal transmitters are being created.
Following me.
I like it to a highway system.
My frontal lobes eradication of a mid-brain is a highway.
I get Lyme disease, I get all this inflammation of my braid, or I get it cushioned, I get it inflammation of my braid, or whatever is causing it.
It's like a flood.
What's a flood new to a highway?
It can wash it out.
How are you going to rebuild it?
You've got to get rid of the flood waters.
Just like, what are my questions about your take exam?
Are you willing to make strict dietary changes?
If you check, though, you are not going to be my patient.
If you won't get rid of gluten, you have an eight-year-old kid with 80-80-80-HC.
They won't stop eating gluten, dairy.
Good luck with that one.
You're never going to help them.
You've got this constant flood.
You do brain-based therapy, tell you, I used to agree.
But you've got this constant flood.
You're going to build up the pathway.
It's like building a road back again.
The flood just continued.
You'd ever deal with the flood.
You had to get the water down.
The biopter in pathway is the chemistry of that.
So when we look at this, this is the biopter in pathway.
Methyl tetrahedral folate comes in here.
It pushes this initial pathway.
These are amino acids that feed the production of dopamine,
nor epidephrine, epidephrine, and serotonin.
Those who are made during transmitters and your brain.
So the genes that we look at are the genes that hold those in place in your brain or degrade them.
The first one is the M-A-O-A gene that degrades serotonin.
So this person has a double-liol defect of that gene.
They're going to have excess serotonin.
If they are having a diet that is full of fetal-ality,
entiracy, the triptophan, they're really going to push this pathway.
They don't get rid of serotonin.
Here's serotonin.
They're making excess because they're eating all protein all day.
So here's a seven-year-old kid with 80-80-80-HD.
All he'll eat is pizza and chicken nuggets.
I can't get him any tails.
Okay, you're a crappy mother.
No, he'll say it.
I don't care.
Just kidding.
Okay, so check your front-to-low communication with that,
because you have to be a parent.
Okay, but you cannot feed this kid all protein all day
because all you're doing is feeding excess dopamine
in excess serotonin.
If they have defects in the comp gene, in the mom gene,
you can't get rid of it.
I feel sorry for the kid.
His brain is just roaring.
He can't stop.
He can't settle down.
Dopamine is just like crazy in this kid.
And you can argue, well, this way this kid is made,
he really shouldn't be sitting in school.
And there's logic there.
If you do have comp gene defects and bond defects,
it's going to be very difficult to sit in school and behave.
It'll make the teacher look at the board and stop looking outside
and stop looking at the squirrel.
However, it is what it is.
And we can do some neural and some chemical adjustments
to help decrease dopamine and serotonin excess production.
Following?
So we're going to take this kid.
This person has defects like that.
And you're going to cut him way back on protein.
We have to look at the other genes too.
It's typically with these really bad cases with kids with ADDU
and he had huge amounts of histamine.
Huge amounts of gut inflammation equals brain inflammation.
So you've got to deal with the gut.
Absolutely, you've got to deal with the diet where I said
I wouldn't take him.
And then you have to look at this question back there.
So why is the difficult treatment an upper?
Because kids' brains react differently to medication
than adult brains do.
There's a metabolic pathway that I can't remember for that.
But if you give a kid a fluoride,
fluoride is going to be an upper for a child.
It's going to be a downer for an adult.
It's going to cause depression and adults.
It's going to cause excitation in a child.
In their brain.
Right, not this.
So this is how you make it or degrade it.
The drugs have different effects on children.
Good question.
Does that make sense?
Still with me?
So it is, okay, let's say I'm not a child.
And I have some issues.
And I have, this is my gene profile.
So I'm looking at mine.
And I have a double-leal mild defect.
So I have all these compound defects.
The wonder I have so much anxiety.
A lot of serotonin, a lot of don't remain in an adult
who has a healthy front along.
Still going to have symptoms of anxiety, OCD.
You know, quick tempered.
Ask your spouse.
Easily agitated.
You get angry and easy.
Probably watching too much Fox News.
But I don't know.
But yeah, you probably are.
You have to do a look at what you're feeding yourself emotionally too, right?
And there's things from a spiritual standpoint that you have to do.
But I have good spiritual people that are saying I'm trying to hold every caught captive
and I feel like I'm going crazy.
You have to look at brain chemistry.
So this is the way you could look at brain chemistry.
You understand you can do a neurotransmitter assessment too.
And look at the levels of neurotransmitter but remember,
those are going to be a photograph of a moving train.
You almost have to do multiple pictures of that.
Because that's going to change throughout the day upon the day.
Follow me.
So from a chemical side, how would you intervene with a patient like this?
You cut down on their proteins?
And there's some specific nutrition that you could address as well.
Are we getting into the next gene?
This is the neurotransmitter profile that you could run as well.
I also wrote a paper on cuff and mouth pathway gene defects that talks about
kind of what I just talked about.
It's available at our website as well.
This is the NOS gene right there that we talked about.
But I don't think I show the slide when we talk about the NOS gene.
But that's in the biopter and pathway.
And when I have defects in this gene, I have excess free
or what's called uncoupled nitric oxide synthase.
And that's what could bond to the excess superoxide ion.
Would I have superoxide dissuptase defects?
The next gene has to do with lube is glutamate.
Now this is something we want to talk about.
How much time do I have?
Okay, so glutamate is really important because it causes a lot of problems.
Matter fact, there's a new report that just came out a few weeks ago
that excess glutamate in your body converts directly to peroxidate trait.
So glutamate is not a good guy.
You need glutamate, right? So don't give me a role.
But almost everybody has excess glutamate.
Especially if you have defects in this gene called your GAN gene.
Your GAN1 gene, well these two genes produce excess glutamate in your body.
But this is how you're supposed to take glutamate and convert it to GABA.
Glutamate is an excitatory neurotransmitter.
It's fine. I need to wake up. I need glutamate, right?
I need to learn, I need glutamate.
However, you have too much excitation of glutamate receptors.
And over and over and over again, you have dementia.
You will burn out glutamate receptors.
There's a good book written on this called Neuroexcital Toxins.
By Dr. Russell Blaylock, he's a neurologist who's converted to our side.
And he writes a lot about glutamate.
Now, you've heard of glutamate in your diet as the modus sodium glutamate in this gene, right?
But there's a whole bunch of different glutamates that, in fact,
it does not have to be labeled anymore.
Thank you, FDA.
And it's labeled as natural and artificial flavorings.
Because they are flavorings.
What they do is they excite the glutamate receptors on your tongue.
They're excitatory. They fire to your brain.
And you go, ooh, that wasn't good.
I'm going to find you another rating of those chips.
So, they're found in processed foods.
Chinese food. I went into a Chinese restaurant a couple of years ago.
It was a brand new Chinese restaurant.
There's a coffee shop in our hotel.
I said, hey, do you use MSG in your food? He goes, I said, what?
I don't believe any Chinese restaurants says they don't use MSG.
We don't sprinkle MSG on our food.
I don't think anybody does, but it all comes with MSG.
It all does.
So, unless it's one of those restaurants that's making everything by scratch,
it definitely has MSG in it.
Because that's what makes it taste better.
Wow, I really like their foods.
Really good.
See, they're the spices. It's the wonderful, organic vegetables you're using,
or it's the MSG.
Because it's excitatory to your tongue.
You want more of it.
Fire's glutamate receptors of the brain.
It burns in the boat.
It's also a lot cheaper than using good ingredients.
Oh, it's a lot cheaper than using good ingredients.
Exactly.
Yes.
So, glutamate is not good in excess.
When you have gad genes, glutamate is supposed to convert to GABA.
And it does truth that through this gene, GABA is a clovey neurotransmitter.
You need GABA to fall asleep.
GABA to relax, to chill.
So, people with excess glutamate don't do that very well.
So, they're highly excitatory.
It could cause anxiety.
I didn't talk about the serotonin of biogeed.
A person can have two little serotonin, right?
It have depression.
So, this biogeed here, if I have those defects,
I can't cycle between too much and two little serotonin, having a gene defect.
But you don't want to confuse depression with anxiety.
Because it isn't finite there.
I have depression.
Really?
Is it truly depression?
Or are you constantly nervous?
And you're constantly worrying.
And you're sad because you're thinking of the worst case scenario all the time.
That's anxiety.
That's not depression.
So, a true depression from a decreased serotonin is going to be a millet colline that has no explanation.
So, there is a difference that you have to be careful with that because you treat it completely opposite from a dietary standpoint.
So, a person with a true depression, you want more serotonin, right?
A person with a true depression, you want more of its precursors.
So, a person that has that is an immediate diet because they don't want to kill animals,
or whatever ethical reason they want to be out of evil diet or their friend is on it,
so they thought it'd be really good too.
And since they started this vegan diet five years ago, their depression has continued to worsen.
It's probably because they have two little serotonin.
Follow it.
They need to get some protein in their body.
Try to treat bold.
It's very tricky.
That's why they work with some people that don't work with other people.
They work at different times, or they work for a period of time, or they stop working.
It's very difficult.
The other reason why you can get depression is this saturated pathway,
and they better not get into any more of that.
But you can pull a triptophan, what I call a triptophan,
steel into the ideal pathway, and you create catalytic acid, which can cause depression.
That's probably the patient that doesn't work with an SRI.
It's really the ideal pathway type depression.
So, excess.
And you also test those patients, and you put a little higher protein,
and it actually makes them worse, because they're steeling their triptophan down the ideal pathway.
So you can see how, can you see a little bit that there's not just like a cookie cutter approach to this?
And the more we try to take a cookie cutter approach,
it only works at a very slow percentage of the patients.
Because you're not a cookie.
Yes, bipolar, there's actually a gene that increases the risk of bipolar.
It's a DAO gene, and so it causes, at least this is the theory right now,
that it causes this LAO gene to work turn it on, basically,
whether they have the defector or not.
So I think that the people with that DAO gene
and the LAO gene defect have a greater degree than bipolar.
It gets afraid of that.
Is it just one of the DAO?
Yes, it is. I think, I don't know if I put another here or not.
I did not. Probably on purpose.
That you're going to be careful with, because the people are like,
oh my god, I got to get that right again.
How do you train it?
The same way that I'm talking about, you have to, but if you like the diet,
and there's some different attrition that you can help with it.
There's a whole bunch of other glutamate genes,
and it's important with glutamate, because if ever I said,
the thylane-conferent cancer, glutamate-conferent cancer too.
So if I'm not converting glutamate, which is this other gene,
this glutamate gene, oh, not that.
The GLS gene.
If I'm not converting glutamate to glutamate,
I'm going to have excess glutamate.
And that can feed cancer as well.
So that's why I'm very careful in how much glutamate,
even though glutamate can be very healing to the slow intestine.
You've got to be very careful how much you use.
So I typically don't use more than a gram a day,
even under cancer patients.
This is the NOS gene that wherever it causes NOS uncoupling.
And that one you would treat even if the person really doesn't have symptoms.
This is the biopterant, how it converts from biopterant to tetrahydrobiopterant.
And then there's other pathways that are important,
vitamin D receptor pathway.
That's very important for patients.
If they have a lot of defects in that pathway,
they need to be tated.
And by the moment they need to be tated higher,
vitamin D level, then clinically,
what would be considered clinically normal?
There's cell membrane protection genes.
This can lead to cancer.
This is a very important gene right here.
The sex horrible binding globular gene for women, especially.
So women in their teens and 20s that have a defect on this gene
are going to be much more susceptible to menstrual issues,
if you have a double allele defect, the chance of you having ovarian cysts
and breast cysts is much greater,
because it affects your ability to hold progesterone issues.
It's actually quite treatable.
So no way that you have that gene.
No way that your eight-year-old girl has that gene.
You could really help prevent a lot of stuff with her,
so that could be really helpful.
In every woman that I've ever tested,
that it has that gene, in fact, that I mentioned just what I said,
goes, oh my gosh, I've had, you know,
I think every woman that I've ever had said,
ah, I had ovarian cysts from,
ah, I had the worst PMS issues with this.
So I think it's very clinically relevant.
Single mutations.
Single mutations get to increase the risk of it.
And then this iron oxidation panel is really,
I think, important to this person.
It doesn't have a lot of defects there.
It's very important.
That's something that's really high with my patients,
is this iron oxidation panel.
Their iron is being oxidized.
So they have symptoms of anemia.
And the worst thing they can do is go on more iron.
So it's just being oxidized.
So there's some specific nutrients that you could help with that.
So that is an extremely helpful,
clinically symptomatically,
that could cause a majority of a person's symptoms too.
With cancer patients, we almost always see MUTL homolog gene defects.
So there's just some of the things that are common with cancer
and not common with Lyme,
Bysomersum,
because our DNA repair genes,
the urea cycle I just mentioned in,
in PASSIUM before,
but that's how you get rid of ammonia in your body.
So if you're producing excess ammonia with CBS defects,
that's the transolpheration pathway.
You're not getting rid of it through the kidney very well.
You're going to have excess ammonia issues,
also with, especially in the ALS gene, I think it is, in here.
You will have an increase in your risk of kidney stones.
So you've got to make sure it's your staying hydrated.
There's a kind of a cool gene that was just research discovered
just a couple of months ago, the CAC gene.
People that have defects in this gene,
this person has none,
have a much higher degree of sensitivity to EMFs.
It's kind of neat.
So I've had a lot of patients that have defects in those genes.
So that's kind of interesting.
And then these are the Lyme study slips that were tested,
that people had defects greater.
This doesn't mean you have Lyme,
but this means if you had Lyme,
what kind of noise you've fitted to, how you've fitted to that.
Oh, that's pretty blurry.
So is this valuable?
It's so helpful.
I didn't just read off the slides that I had taught you guys.
You guys got at least a gravel road on how genetics work right now.
What labs do we use for what test?
The Lyme test.
So these Lyme steps have to do with us putting together,
this is the 23 of me, yes.
This doesn't tell you you have Lyme,
but this was a study that we did,
by we, I mean the genetic nutrition people did,
with 150 known chronic Lyme patients.
They took all that volunteered to give them their genetic data.
And it was interesting to see the uptick that all chronic Lyme patients had in certain genes.
So, so everything that I told you today is the 23 of me,
except I showed you a little slip of,
maybe I didn't work as a test,
or a little slip of neuro-transmitter test.
But everything I showed you that looks like boxes like this
is from the data from the 23 of me, yes.
Absolutely not.
So the right helps with that.
So if that EMF you'd really talk to them about
you have to really be careful to groan your house.
So I don't like spigot to using groans for your bed.
That's a good piece to do,
but that's only groaned you while you're in bed.
So you're not in bed all day long.
So where is your biggest source of EMFs coming from?
Well, in the house it's coming from your electrical panel,
it's coming from your biker wave,
it's coming from your electrical equipment,
your television, and your cell phone, right?
Where's the external EMFs coming from?
The biggest is from cell phone towers, smart beaters, yeah.
From high power lines.
So all these are EMFs, right?
Our ancestors built wigwabs on the ground and walked barefoot, right?
So you were constantly grounding yourself.
Of course they didn't have smart beaters and cell phone towers either.
So we are insulting our body with electromagnetic frequencies
that are that are doing ill health to us.
So they're at the frequency life that are hurting us
whereas the true right is not at a frequency that's hurting us,
it's not a frequency life that's helping us.
So using the right is actually helping block EMFs.
But you're not using the right point for hours today either.
So you still have to do things like,
this is a brand new cell phone that I just got, right?
And I don't have my protection on there.
We use a disc called a hydro disc that's a company on a Wisconsin
but a patient that uses another company that he really likes too.
So there are some cell phone protectors that are really good.
We use to ground people's houses with a product that is a ground basalt
that would help pull EMFs out in the house.
It worked fairly well.
Now we use this hydro that makes a whole house disc that we use
that makes it a little easier for people but it's still going to ground your house.
A salt simply has zero charge.
Remember, EMFs have a positive charge.
The grove has a negative charge.
So when you're grounding yourself and you're walking on the grove
outside barefoot, you're groving yourself.
That's why you feel better when you go walk the beach.
Because you're groving yourself.
That's why pets are good for you.
Your dog is outside running around groving itself
and you comb your pet it and you discharge all the positive electrons on your dog.
I'm going outside and play again.
That's why people feel better when they get out of horse.
That's why horse therapy works so good.
The horse is standing on the floor.
Grounded hooves all day long.
You put a child that's 80-80-80-80-80.
Their head is just like spinning.
You put about a horse and they settle down.
Because you're discharging all that positive electrons that are not good for you.
What? Spell groving?
Hydron. We sell about our website for cheaper than you could buy it from Hydron.
So groating yourself is good for your brain.
So we talked about brain pathology just a little bit about brain chemistry,
about the neurological part of brain and the physical part of your brain.
And I'm a functional neurologist too.
Then I don't do that as much anymore.
But it's fascinating.
It's really important if you're going to stay healthy with your brain.
So with our line patients, what are the things we do to help build those pathways
is using neurofeedback.
So the neurofeedback connect electrons to your brain
and you're running a computer program with your brain basically.
It's very extremely helpful when you have bad and bad brains.
Yes, you had a question.
Hi, from Coastal Concert.
Really good for you. You should eat as much as you can.
I knew you were excited about that.
Yeah, it's toxic, right?
Does it affect the brain?
I think so.
And I think it's a contributor to Alzheimer's and amyloid plaques by itself.
But I don't know if there's research on that or not.
But it's in hot and responsible.
Absolutely.
It's an increased diabetes rates.
Yeah.
Again, remember my whole approach is, I don't think there's this early one thing that's the bad,
the total bad guy.
And that's why these studies are never completely conclusive.
Because okay, at all these diabetes patients, not all of them had
worked both to high for Coastal Concerts.
Because there's other things as well.
You've got to look at the giant picture of it.
So, yes, those are some things that you should remove from your diet, you know,
as much as humanly possible.
Yes.
Can I connect them three up?
Three or four?
No.
So it's 23andMe, the one that's adding new data.
Yes and no.
So I have patients that did their 23andMe two years ago.
Well, 23andMe is adding SNPs that they're testing for.
But they're not adding them, you know, that big of increments.
So if a person did their 23andMe right when 23andMe came out,
then I might say, maybe you should run it again.
It's not that the data that was that you had positive SNPs aren't going to change.
It's just that they're running more SNPs though.
Because on some reports that people read it several years ago,
it'll say, it ain't there, it ain't there, it ain't there, it ain't there.
Because they didn't run those chips then.
And then so that it's helpful to have is bored.
But if you ran it the last year, you know, you don't have to run it again.
Back there.
Do I have concerns about personal data security with 23andMe having your gene profiles?
I personally don't.
It's like I don't care if the government listens to my phone calls either.
But it's anything.
So it's, what are they going to do?
I don't know.
I mean, it's like, what are they going to do with a million people?
I just don't.
I mean, I'm as much of a conspiracy theorist as the next person, probably.
But then you get to avoid them.
What would they do with that?
What would they listen to my emails?
I don't care if they read my emails, you know?
So it's like, I just don't.
Yes.
Excitotoxins.
You have to live it.
So it's patient by patient.
So you've got to kind of watch them.
And so I use glutamate.
But I, like the product that we use, which is called our clear GI that has the only one.
And I use that, I use that, spiritly.
You know, a full dosage only has a full daily dosage.
It only has 100 milligrams in it.
Where I have some patients that come in, they're taking 5 grams of glutamated.
It's like, I don't care who you are, that's way too much.
So if you watch the dosage out, and plus look at the genes that convert glutamate.
If they have a lot of defects there, then you're probably safer with a little higher dosage.
Because they're not converted into glutamate very well.
So you're safer with that.
And you should look at their intestinal transit time.
Because if they're like losing it, if it's not stay in there very long,
then I would make sure you dose it out.
And I like to do GI health things in a drink that they drink.
And if you're taking 900 milligrams at night o'clock in the morning,
you know, you have a half life of every nutrient that you take.
So it's going to be gone by one.
So with something like that, when I say 900 milligrams a day,
every 900 milligrams in a whole day, and I don't like to bulk it.
So they're spreading it out throughout the whole day.
I forgot it was on here.
It's actually a brand new gene that we just pulled out last week actually.
So to answer your question, how do we know we need to update it?
Our software is updated as we find out what those genes do.
23B already runs the gene, but they don't know what it does yet.
So as the data comes out, we know what that gene does that our software updates.
And I actually call some patients back and say, hey, stick it to you.
Actually, I have to call some patients back.
My staff does this week.
Stick it to you.
Here's a possible reason why we got stuck there is now it shows this.
So of course, update their profile.
It'll update my system to everything new and it will be able to see.
Three minutes left.
Yes.
With EMFs, usually neurological symptoms.
So, well, brain fog and anything.
I mean, you could have pain.
It could be an upper motor issue.
It's affecting the frion alone with the brain.
Yes.
Yeah.
So again, it's so the parents like, oh, if you come in, you're a live patient or you're a cancer patient,
you're going through three.
So, I mean, that's just across the board.
From a dietary standpoint.
And though there are G defects, the rest are diet.
So I don't think everybody should be vegan.
I don't think everybody should be paleo.
I don't think that.
So everybody's a little bit different.
Supplements that I use are, I use, I probably use about 15 different supplement companies.
So, a lot of the genetics supplements are from professional health products.
But there's a big mixture.
So, it's really hard because I use, if I find one good supplement from one company, I use that.
So, behind you there.
There's no guarantee that there got, if it's really bad damage, it's just going to eat after glow to be there.
There's no guarantee on that.
Yeah, but again, it's, you know, so dietary things, it makes a big difference in what you're eating it with.
So, if you're having a piece of chicken, how many milligrams of glutamate is in that?
I don't know, 500 milligrams of glutamate.
But, it's got other amino acids that you're competing with.
Yeah, so it's a balance.
So, it's even, if you're part of a person on a low protein diet because this kid has comp defects.
And you don't want to feed that triptophan, fetalality, and tyrosine pathway to make more dopamine.
It's not that you can't have protein.
But, maybe he shouldn't just eat chicken nuggets.
You know, maybe he needs to eat chicken nuggets.
He's got to eat his vegetables too, or it's it.
You know, it's a matter of what else are you eating with that?
It's the same thing with histamines.
You know, if you're just going to have a bottle of kombucha, that's a lot of histamines.
But, if you're going to have some kombucha with your meal of vegetables,
then you're deluded that spike of that specific nutrient.
So, it's all about food combination too, and how much you're spiking things.
We're cutting it off. We're done.